so last week we visited the cork tree
factory and also uh the harvesting so
you could see how the bark is taking off
and processed in a factory into cork
and we actually used to have three big
cork trees on the land ourselves this
one right here
still standing near the bottom yoga deck
this is the only one that didn't burn
down and we used to have two other ones
and here's another cork tree underneath
my feet i'm walking on it right now
because it collapsed a few months ago
makes you realize how big these things
are that you can just really walk on top
of them
um but here you can see actually how it
went so it got hit by a fire
uh burned but kept being alive but then
some windy day
eventually the whole thing did crack and
collapse
which is a shame because it was a very
beautiful tree close to base camp
and the third torque tree was actually
located right here but there isn't a
tree anymore
because we actually used it
and this tree
also was burned down fell on the
neighborland he dumped it on our land so
we could use it
and but it was there just rotting away
so last winter we started to process it
so in this video i'm gonna show you
what we did with it all the cool things
we made and we're actually also going to
bake some bread
in our clay made pizza oven so yeah
welcome to a new project camp update
let's rewind
so the tree has actually already been
here for a while and with winter coming
it slowly starts to rot away even more
and so it's a good time to chop it so
we're gonna make some
little stools and a little table out of
it hopefully
and we could actually borrow
chainsaw which is super long so we can
really cut through the thick parts
let's start
[Music]
so here we have a nice selection of wood
however i did notice a lot of them
already started to rot
like here
get some mold on it
some animals living in there so we might
want to
scrape off the outer edges to make sure
they don't rot anymore
[Music]
so here's the biggest part of the tree
and it's quite big like even this big
chainsaw as you can see it won't reach
all the way
and so here we can probably make a nice
table out of it
and
these two parts they might look smaller
but they also come together here
creating probably the biggest piece of
it all so uh
yeah let's see if we can chop them down
with that small chainsaw
[Applause]
[Music]
and it took quite a while to go through
this old dance wood
but we managed to cut out a few good
pieces it's a rough cut and still need
some clean up but lifting them up is
impossible way too heavy so when our
neighbor drove by with his front loader
on his tractor we asked for some help
but they were actually also too heavy
for lifting with his tractor so we had
another creative way
[Music]
[Music]
it's huge
[Music]
okay
we dragged out all the pieces that we
thought would be somewhat useful
including this burned up piece potential
bench
and here's the heaviest one of them all
wanted to put them up for a while so
they could dry up from that winter
humidity they've been in
and just as a reference to show how big
they are here is one spanish guy next to
a quark
and as you see the cork still has some
bark around it
if you want to know about what you can
do with that have a look at our previous
video where we visit the place where
they harvest and process cork
but the cork isn't that usable anymore
since the bark already started to
decompose and became a resource for
another species
many mushrooms and worms in there
feels bad to take away their house but
it also feels bad seeing all this
valuable cork root rot away
could still be used for many years
so after dragging all the pieces in base
camp we let them dry for a while and
after that ready for cutting
first up a simple table from this big
chunk
next up this massive block
and the first step was to take off the
bark
and looking at the tape measure it seems
like actually two tables are hidden in
there
but we can't cut it like this so yeah i
guess we just flip it over and cut
easy
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and finally this rough one a bench sort
of well with a few simple cuts it could
probably be very useful
[Music]
[Music]
so after all of this we also had a few
small pieces laying around so we cut
those up as a little pathway to keep
your feet clean after the shower
at this point we're just looking for
applications to make sure the car
doesn't rot away
so
once we cutted a bunch of stuff now it's
time to actually install it all in
basecamp let me show you how we are
using them right now a few months later
so this is the final result now we have
a super cool bench
this bench was
chopped down as you might have seen
this was a bit sanded and oiled
in front we have this little table a
living table with some of big mushrooms
here we can work a bit drink some tea
whatever but just being in a space under
the shade
but even better there is this space
right here
that is really under the shade is
perfect for meetings
and this again was also super sanded and
treated like with some linseed oil
so that it resists a bit better to the
weather
and geran created a few beautiful
gardens here we expect in a few years
that this is all covered up with jasmine
or some climbing
plants
and besides all of these places
tim also created another super beautiful
space in this direction which is right
there
so you guys might not really feel but
the temperature is super different here
there is some breeze and under the shape
this is just the ideal place to
have some meetings even better than on
the deck because here the shade is from
the trees so it really cools down the
area
[Music]
this is one of the biggest parts of the
court tree
also treated with oil and sand it
[Music]
some hammocks just to enjoy a bit the
siestas and when the heat goes up
tim has making some experiments with me
moses and one of the experiments was
this
i don't know pull-up bar i personally
wouldn't be able to do it
and i wouldn't do it
but this is a super cool addition also
to the land
and with the
leftover bits we create benches all
around the camp this one is a nice one
just next to the kitchen with a little
heart
also we chopped a few
thinner bits that serve as steps
we can go up
or we can go down much easier just just
follow the path after the shower
that actually leads us
to the
space that we will clean up today
uh
the
cork bench is there or the car table is
there you'll just clear all of this put
some wood chips
ready to go
so this action will be made by colleen
and i colleen just arrived she's a great
addition to the team
hello i'm colleen and i'm here for two
months and today we're getting some
bushes and removing some nasty spikes
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
colleen
what we are doing now
so we cleared up the area so that means
that the soil is very exposed now
because we took out of the
soil and brambles so we're going to put
wood chips in it and it will allow the
soil to be
more conserved to not be too much in the
heat and also to have a comfortable
mattress for our little feet when we're
resting oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
oh my goodness this is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so this place is done
it's super cool now this will be very
shaded during the day will be super nice
to hang out here
now we took rumbles away and we replaced
it with wood chips so much better for
the feet
we also took out a lot of big wood big
mimosa and they're at the moment stuck
on a big pile
this pile is gonna get chopped in pieces
and put under the oven so then when
we're gonna do the bread we're gonna use
those wood
so now
we are off because we're gonna watch a
movie without you
so we should go
bye-bye
and another ongoing project we have here
is our research and bread making making
a bread yourself every now and then
isn't too hard but we're trying to find
a way to realistically integrate it in
our weekly routine baking community
amounts and using a wood-fired clay oven
yeah it's quite a mission so we have an
ongoing research topic in our module
where you can find more information
about it
starting with burn brat and gradually
improving let me show you what's the
current state of our baking process
hello who are you
hello hi felix i'm ted i'm from
netherlands and i'm the vegan chef here
project gum for about two months
and today we're gonna make sourdough
bread and we'll start with the first
step and the first step we'll make
and we'll explain to you what level is
hmm
so you came after aggie right yes i came
after aagi nice okay cool let's start
um well this is the the starter for the
sourdough so that's a culture you keep
on feeding
so it becomes wild yeast
this starter is called bird so it is as
a name you have to take care of it
and we're going to take two scoops of
this starter and we're going to mix it
with equal parts of flour and water to
make the laven which will be the
kickstarter for making a sourdough bread
so that's gonna make sure the sourdough
bread is actually gonna ferment and
leave them
so it doesn't go super precise but we
take about two scoops of sourdough
starter
we measure our amount of flour because
we want
equal parts of flour and water
so it's going to be 100 hydration in
your event and after that you're going
to
play with hydration in your dough but
then levine 100 hydration so equal parts
water and flour
[Music]
[Music]
just getting tap water
[Music]
how long are you gonna wait till you
make the dough out of it
um so we're gonna let this sit overnight
um so it's gonna ferment all the way
it's gonna double in size
so it's gonna rise
and ferment all night and then tomorrow
morning we can use it
so we have here the starter already fat
the laven
and later or tomorrow we're gonna do the
dough yes that's it that's it so bird is
gonna live inside the fridge again so we
don't need to feed it constantly so
we're gonna let it go to sleep
so the fermentation the yeast is less
active in the in the starter so it's
gonna go back into the fridge
uh so we cover the van with the wet
cloth to uh to keep it moist and inside
the bowl to make sure it doesn't uh
dehydrate during the
during the fermentation process can we
see it tomorrow again
see you tomorrow
so it's the next morning
and we're now of all the components to
make our sourdough
so first we have the levant that we
already made yesterday so this fermented
overnight and it became a lively culture
next to that
we have our flour of course
it contains 80 whole wheat flour and 20
white flour
we have water
and we have
salt we're gonna mix all these
ingredients together and make one
cohesive dough um so let's do it
okay so we start with the levant we mix
that in first so we're gonna mix in the
van and after the water to spread
the yeast throughout the water and make
sure it's spread out to dough in a later
stage as well
so now we pour in the water
let me give it a good stir
so that
the van mixes in with water
so we can
mix in the
flour and salt
how much flour is that
this is two and a half kilos of flour so
we'll make
four loaves
[Music]
and it's about 50 grams of salt so two
percent of the
weight of the flour
[Music]
[Music]
how long it's gonna rest
um
it's gonna
it's gonna rest for
four hours yeah i mean normally it's i
would say six to eight hours but now i
think four to five hours with this
temperatures
because it's 30 degrees plus here so
i would say four to five hours
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
now the door has risen so it's like
fluffy
you can push it a little bit and it
bounces back
so we know it's ready
[Music]
here
[Music]
uh we roughly shaved the dough but we
baked them in
baking tray so they don't need to be
shaped that much but you do want to
build up a little bit of tension in
[Music]
the top part of the of the dough so it
will rise better once it's in the oven
[Music]
okay
ready to be back
[Music]
and some water yeah some water to create
some steam
so they don't directly seal
the crust doesn't
how long do they bake
uh they bake about 45 minutes
normally but
with this oven it's always a little bit
yeah you have to see a little bit and
see how to develop
take them out see whether they're good
so 45 minutes at least i would say but
maybe up to an hour
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i liked it
[Music]
[Music]
all right so that was it for this video
thank you guys for watching if you
already want to see the next video make
sure to support on patreon
or not and we'll just see you again next
week same time same channel bye
[Music]
you